last question today Peter guys what was
the biggest sexual scandal at any
schools you went to I remember which was
the biggest sexual scandal at a school I
went to in my high school there was a
police officer a resource officer and
that resource officer had sex with one
of the students and was ultimately
relocated elsewhere I think that the
resource officer may have actually lost
his job eventually and it was one of
those things where it was unspoken but
everybody sort of knew about it and it
was confirmed by you know I I wasn't
friends with the the young lady that was
involved but later many friends in
common of ours said it was not just a
rumor she's admitted it it's absolutely
true that was definitely the biggest
sexual sexual scandal at any school I've
been to and was the the young lady who
was involved with she at the age of
consent for that to happen
you know I don't I don't believe that
she does yeah so I think it I think it
would have been a statutory rape yeah
that should be there should be much
bigger consequences for that than just
losing your job is I believe it was
brushed under the under the carpet
by-and-large yeah the police officer was
I would guess somewhere in his early 30s
and even even if she was a see it's
possible that this was at the end of
senior year and that she was 18 maybe I
mean I just don't remember exactly when
it was but odds are that she was not 18
at the time and even if she was I mean
there's a whole power dynamic there
which yeah this isn't right I mean
someone has a position of authority over
you even if it is consensual yeah you
shouldn't be going around doing no doubt
about it no doubt about it was there
anything like that at any school you
went to I can't remember any particular
sexual scandal the one thing that did
come to mind and this is this is pretty
bad was someone sprayed their human
feces over one of the toilet stalls okay
and actually drew a swastika with it and
began becoming he became known as the
pooper trader okay the entire school
yeah we eventually did find out who it
was
that's that's a clear sign of mental
illness I would have to say oh yeah if
you're you know
around with that there and the uh it's
interesting because Trump seems to me
like like the guy you'd find out is
collecting his feces at home but anyway
that that's story probably for another
day wouldn't shock me to hear that but
yeah my a lot of people in my family
including my dad have worked in mental
health for decades and in a number of
different inpatient outpatient scenarios
and starting to sort of do weird things
with bodily wastes is it's not that rare
right you see it as part of different
conditions that people may be struggling
with but yeah that's not good I mean
that's not just kid hijinks that's
requires some pretty serious treatment
that's pretty bad and even though we
were in high school it was at a time
when we had to sign out to go to the
bathroom right and they were able to
catch the person because he just signed
out I mean that was how they did it you
signed out in the class you were in in
the class that you were in the time that
you went out in the time that you came
back so they could just kind of have
some accountability for everyone I guess
in case a scenario like this happened so
they were able to cross check who in all
classes who was signed out roughly at
the time that they determined had
happened and they worked it back now was
he caught brown handed no but he
eventually did admit to it probably was
suspended that's pretty bad yeah I mean
it's more sad than anything else it's
always vile but if somebody's doing that
it's it what we have no I have no clue
what was going on in this person's life
but there's probably an analysis to be
done about what led to such behavior
yeah I mean that that's a pretty bad
sign
great bonus show for you today instant
access to the bonus show comes only one
way by going to david pakman.com slash
membership and of course if normal
membership rates strike you as a bit
high we have a coupon code
I voted 17 all lowercase all one word
which will give you a big discount off
of the membership of your choice speak
to you on the bonus show